The similar message is further repeated
in the Vedas. If you read the Rigid
chapter number 32 verse number three, it
says of that God there is no pratima.
There is no image, there is no
photograph, there is no picture, there
is no painting, there is no portrait,
there is no statue, there is no
sculpture, there is no idol. It's
further mentioned in Yajurve chapter
number 40 verse number 8. Almighty God
is imageless and pure. It's mentioned in
chapter number 40 verse number 9 and
provanti they and mean darkness.
Pravishanti means entering they are
entering darkness those who worship the
asamuti. Asamuti are natural things like
fire, water, air. And the verse
continues they are entering more in
darkness those who worship the sambuti
the created things like table chair
idols etc. Who says that? Almighty God
in the Hindu scriptures in Jajuru
chapter number 40 verse number 9. It's
further mentioned in Atarave book number
20 him number 58 verse number three D
Maha Oen verily great is almighty God
and amongst the Veda the most sacred are
the mentioned in
rigid book number two hymn number one.
There are no less than 33 different
attributes given to almighty god in
rivid book number two hymn number one.
One amongst them is
brahma. Brahma is the creator
god. If you translate
creator into Arabic it is khalik. So we
Muslims have got no objection to someone
calls almighty god as creator or khalik
or brahma. But if someone says Brahma is
almighty god who has got four heads and
on each head is a crown. We Muslims take
strong objection to it because you're
giving an image to almighty god and
going
against chapter number four number 19 we
says of that god there is no image.
The other attribute given in rigid book
number two hymn number one is Vishnu.
Vishnu is the sustainer. The
cherisher the sustainer god. The
cherisher god. If you translate
cherisher or sustainer into Arabic it is
r. We Muslims have got no objection if
someone says almighty god is r or
sustainer or cherisher or vishnu. But if
someone says Vishnu is almighty
God who has got four hands and he's
traveling on the sea on the bed of
snakes or traveling on a bird named as
Garuda and has four hands one of his
right hand has the chakra and the left
hand has a conch. We Muslims take strong
objection to it because you're giving an
image to almighty God and going against
chapter number three to verse number
three he says
Of that God there is no
image. Further if you read it's
mentioned in
digit book number eight hymn number one
verse number
one. Do not worship anyone but one god.
Praise him alone. It's mentioned in
rigid book number six hymn number 45
verse number
16. Praise him alone and no one else.
And the Brahma Sutra, the fundamental
creed of Hinduism
is there's only one God, not a second
one, not at all. Not at all, not in the
least bit. So if you read the Hindu
scriptures, you'll understand the
concept of God in Hinduism and
understand Hinduism in the correct
perspective, in the right perspective.